the final season of Picard is nearly
upon us but will it be the final voyages
for Jean-Luc Picard welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
[Music]
so we've been told that Picard season 3
is the final season of this television
show but does that mean the end of
Jean-Luc Picard well apparently not
during the television critics
Association 2023 winter press tour a new
trailer for Picard season 3 was released
following that there was a panel and
Patrick Stewart and Alex kurtzman
appeared and discussed their thoughts on
the show and answered questions from the
Associated Press
during those questions Alex kurtzman and
Patrick Stewart was straight up asked is
this the end of Picard Patrick should
have said well if the storytelling of
the production everyone else is as good
a qualities these three seasons he would
be willing to return and Alex kurdsman
said hey come on who knows the door is
always open we'll see what happens and
if this television series blows the
doors off like they hope it will
basically if it's massively successful
like they hope it will be then Anything
is Possible we've also had tweets from
Marina certis and Gates McFadden
basically saying two trekkies look would
you like to see more episodes with us in
would you like to see more Star Trek
with the original TNG crewing and to be
honest the answer from the tweets I saw
was an overwhelming oh God hell yes
we already in love characters like wolf
and we would love to see them return and
have enjoyed seeing even Riker back on
the screen too I have to admit was never
my favorite TNG character but hey but
what do I think about this news that
Patrick Stewart might not be hanging up
the Spurs and could go on to appear in
more track well a lot of people have
been saying well could this be another
Picard series I very much doubt it I
honestly think this is the end of
Picard's Standalone television series
it's been put as the final voyages the
final season it would be very difficult
for them to go back on that but could
Picard appear in another television
series well we know that when Picard
ends the chances are another television
series will be announced probably very
close around the premiere date now
there's been a lot of rumors the one I
heard most recently was they were
considering a Titan Series so obviously
the capital ship the the main ship that
we're going to be seeing during Picard
season 3 does seem to be the Titan now
love it or hate it I personally am still
in kind of two minds about it you see
that ship at certain angles and you
think oh my God it's awful and then you
see it flying at warp and like spinning
shots and things and you think it looks
great so um we'll see when the series
comes along but
if they did have a series with the Titan
as the main ship and it was just a
monster of the week this is the Voyages
of the USS Titan with seven of nine as
Captain dear God I would watch the crap
out of that show I am really hoping that
whatever kurdsman decides to do with a
new Star Trek series if in fact it
happens is that they will do something
that is more contemporary too like the
Next Generation two strange new worlds a
ship flying around exploring the
universe exploring the Federation and
just basically not overthinking it no
over complicating it I'm also hoping
that it's contemporary in the timeline
of Picard and they don't do another
bloody prequel because to be honest I'm
sick of them so could Picard return in
whatever that new series was well as I
say the other crew Gates McFadden and
The Marina certainty seem to be at the
front of this I've already suggested
that could there be a further series a
further set of adventures with the
original TNG crew in I've always wanted
to see Wharf return and Michael Dawn has
talked about doing sort of a wharf
series for many years he even went as
far as having ideas and tried to pitch
it several times to Paramount could that
be a possibility for the future I would
really hope so one thing we can be
reasonably certain of is that chances
are that plans around things like
section 31 have probably been rethought
I do wonder if the popularity and the
reaction to Strange New worlds to be
honest has made kurtzman have a think
and maybe go back to the drawing board
and a lot of those projects and again
hopefully projects like Starfleet
Academy which is again something that
was been rumored and discussed several
times is also going to be scrapped
because I don't want to see Star Trek
90210 I don't want to see a teen drama a
bass drum Starfleet I just don't please
don't do it please God I have to say
though that Picard seasons one and two
disappointed me I was so excited about
both of these series and then they even
both started really really well but then
they meandered they tripped and they
faltered and they ended up being very
disappointed again Picard season 3 looks
like it's going to be incredibly
exciting the action sequences from what
we've seen already look amazing but
again there are elements going on in
this story that are concerning me we've
seen Moriarty returning and fans to be
honest went crazy even though they were
very confused how on Earth could the
Moriarty character from the TNG appear
in this new series last time we saw him
he was on a data crystal in that little
box thing aboard the Enterprise the
Enterprise that then crashed so how on
Earth could he now be in this future
episode of Picard we also got to see law
another character that we never really
got to find out what happened to him
following the last couple of episodes of
The Next Generation but now seems to be
old and have skin but the forge
recognized him immediately as law so
he seemed to be making a return
I don't see how that's possible and I
really don't see how the villains that
we've seen so far are connected but I'm
hoping they are there to be a coherent
storyline I mean it does feel a bit like
a Sinister Six kind of thing where a
main villain is bringing back several
villains in an attempt to take on Picard
and the crew if it is as simple as that
then it's going to be stupid also I just
don't see how Moriarty the primarily
Moriarty returns to this series and it
not be silly original episode when Jordy
and dato were in the hollow deck and
they're doing the Sherlock Holmes
stories and Jordan Forge accidentally
asks a computer Creator villain that can
defeat data instead of one that can
defeat a Sherlock Holmes and the
computer created a self-aware Moriarty
was brilliant it was such a clever
episode and it ended very cleverly as
well but to bring him back into this
Picard series
the reasons for his return are going to
have to be equally as clever as the
original episode was for it to make any
bloody sense at all and to be honest so
far the creators of Picard haven't shown
me that they have any such intelligence
or any such imagination to create a
storyline for what they've teased us so
far to make any sense
so what is my confidence level on Picard
season three
I'm hopeful I'm really hopeful these
characters deserve a brilliant season to
go out on
put
my pragmatic side my cynical side
I give a 50 50 at best but guys get in
the comments to what you think do you
want to see Picard in some future
iteration of Star Trek or is that
something you think you know what
Patrick you've done an amazing job but
that's enough now
I'd also love to know what you think
about Picard season three in general and
what would you like to see replace it
when it comes to an end get in the
comments and tell me exactly what you
think also if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you want to support the channel even
further because they're hitting that
join Button as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you